i uh accidentally flipped my friend's
quad bike over oh my that's dangerous
yeah that was dangerous we were riding
quad bikes in like the mud and i was
like this is the coolest [ __ ] thing
ever yeah like you know i was like 12.
yeah and then
he was like don't go too fast though and
i'm i was like a danger kid i would just
like love going too fast doing [ __ ] like
that
and uh yeah i think they also call that
an idiot yeah
listen i should have been i should have
won a darwin award yeah yeah and so i'm
like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] quad i start doing like uh
donuts with this quad bike right and
then yeah it just flips over and i flip
in it but i'm so small that like i like
get down in the arch and like when i
fall to the side like don't hit my head
or anything
cause like yeah i think like quad bike
accidents like deaths like a very calm
yeah it wasn't like super fast it was
just me being stupid and turning but i
just fell off jesus christ yeah
dangerous dangerous yeah don't do that
don't don't don't flip bikes yeah yeah
because like i remember i remember like
i'd i never like i had i knew one person
in my school who owned like a quad bike
and he was like the [ __ ] cool kid
right if you have like farms everyone
like that like a lot of people had them
yeah i mean like the only reason this
guy this uh this guy the quad bike or
this kid out of the quarterback was
because his dad had won the lottery
right so he was like he was why is it
when you get too rich you buy a
quadcopter i don't know because there's
no practical use for a quad bike right
right
it's just to have if you have too much
land you get a quad bike yeah so you can
get around the land
yeah so he was just like he was a cool
kid because he was the kid that owned a
quad bike and like it was like the kid
that like you'd want to be friends
because you knew that you'd made it when
he'd invite you around his house yeah
because like you'd hear you'd hear
stories about how people went to this
kid's house and like i went on a quad
bike
it's either that one kid that owns a
quad bike or that one kid whose dad
works in an i.t company and owns every
game console oh yeah everyone had that
one friend
my friend was both oh really oh my god
his dad was a son
that was a farmer so he had all the quad
bike and all that stuff but he also had
all the game consoles and i always used
to love going because he had pokemon
colosseum on the gamecube
and i was like this is insane you can
the pokemon are like 3d
what
so we'd have a day of like quad biking
and then
his mom would make amazing food and then
uh
yeah and so i just like never wanted to
leave his house and luckily like i slept
slept over this house so many goddamn
times and i loved staying at his house
yeah i had that one friend too that was
like it was amazing it was so much fun i
loved i loved going to his house that
was like the best child of memories yeah
except where i knew he died on the quad
bank of course that was my own fault
that was my own fault that's fair enough
but bikes are fun though yeah
there was really oh they're so fun
they're pretty easy to drive have i been
on one i don't think i have been online
actually it's like a stable bike
until it flips over yeah
so like that we used to go to like the
you know what i was saying about like
the kayaking thing yeah there was
another place that was kind of a similar
thing had like swimming pool and all
that and it also had quad bikes are you
allowed to ride but they put like safety
pins or something in it that limited the
speed so you couldn't go above a certain
speed and it was painfully slow yeah and
one of the kids who owned the quad bike
knew how to remove it right and then so
we were all doing laps right going
really slow on these bikes
it suddenly is this one kid's turn and
the teachers like looked away for a
second and he'd go back this kid's going
like [ __ ] tearing up all the like
dirt just flinging it and all the
teachers and stuff like absolutely
tearing up the track and they couldn't
stop him right because he's going too
fast yeah you could like get in the way
yeah and so he's going super fast he
gets the bollocking of his life but it
was so funny just watching him like
destroy this this like land that had
been finally made it was just like
tearing up the mud and [ __ ] destroy it
all so funny do you guys have any
experiences uh with motorbikes or
anything like that no i wish i'd love to
drive them i've been on the back of a
motorbike many times but it's it's scary
it's [ __ ] terrifying i want to learn
how to ride one
i've thought about it but then i've also
heard of every single person i've ever
known who used to ride a motorbike is
it's all past tense they used to ride a
motorbike because most of the time they
get in horrible accidents i just want to
ride one i want to know how to drive one
what if i'm like i just need to ride a
motorcycle one day
i was tempted to get like uh in japan
like getting like a motorhead license
yeah because apparently you can get it
in like one day it's like yeah you just
have to do like a test and you pay like
60 bucks or something yeah
60 sucks
60 bucks
yeah you pay like 60 bucks for a test
and then you can just get it in like a
couple of hours yeah you just have to
buy it if you're like james bond chase
you need to drive a motorcycle you know
i'm gonna drive moped [ __ ]
like if you go to thailand you're
probably going to have to ride a
motorcycle
when i say motorcycle it's not like a
[ __ ] harley davidson or something
it's it's it's the southeast asian like
kind of like moped motorcycles where
it's like a scooter right like a scooter
yeah i thought motocross was really cool
as well right yeah like like like that
kind of like that kind of bike i guess
yeah but like i've been on on enough
[ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ]
mo like moped motorbike taxi drivers
that it's just
put me off from ever wanting to learn a
motorbike and like the one time that i
tried learning how to ride a motorbike
which was one of these bikes mind you
and i remember of course it was in
thailand and uh like i remember like if
you want to get around but not want to
own a car then you'd learn how to drive
a motorcycle right that's that's what
that's the cheap way to go about it i
mean that's why in topki and the vietnam
special they didn't have cars they had
motorbikes right stolen a lot huh they
get stolen a lot i assume i've never
owned one so i would assume so probably
right but like i remember like the only
time i've tried to learn how to ride one
was i was i was i've had like enough
like scary experience with motorbikes
that i've just never wanted to learn
and i remember like i remember my dad
was just like come on come on you gotta
learn how to drive come on we're in town
you gotta learn how to drive one
eventually yeah and i remember he like
builds this i'd like my entire family
like build this idea up of me having to
like at least give it a try of how to
learn how to ride a motorbike and i
remember this one time
i was like okay fine i'll give it i'll
give it a try i'll give it a try it's
just like it's just like riding a bike
right it's just like riding a bike right
now i'm just like just like riding a
bike and it's it was like a one-for-one
recreation of like my car experience
right
because i remember i remember my dad
after building up all this courage we
have uh we have like my uh we have like
my cousin's motorbike that i could try
out and just start learning with and my
dad like brings me over to the bike and
goes okay just sit on this bike okay and
what you need to do just just try just
try like just like give you that much
confidence he's like stuck you on it
yeah he stopped me on it and he just
like he just twisted a bit he just just
twisted a bit just just give it a bit of
a rev and me like like a one for one
thinking a little bit of a bit of a
twist is fifty percent
[Laughter]
god
you can't you can't like do this yeah
you can only do fifty percent
immediately
rev forward i immediately fall down and
like the motorbike falls down on me i'm
like all right no i'm never getting on
one again
i'm just reminded of all those videos of
like where they thank you where they
like rev the motorbike
just comes over them yeah
i really want to learn like i don't know
like a lot of quote unquote like
dangerous vehicles i'd love to learn how
to drive i really want to learn how to
drive a speedboat i don't know why i've
never even been in a like a speech boat
i've been in a speedboat i've never been
in the street i
at least in sydney we used to have uh
like we had like a ferry service because
we were like in a bay but you'd also get
what's called uh a water cat which is
basically think of like uh it's a taxi
like a water taxi but it's instead of a
taxi it's a speed boat yeah i know the
ones and you get on them dude those
things are [ __ ] scary they look so
funny they're so fast like i want to
ride a jet ski i've never ridden jet ski
in my life i want to write a jet ski
because i thought jet skis are fun
that's like the college frat boy [ __ ]
oh yeah i just want to ride one it looks
so fun yeah still a student in thailand
yeah
it's it's very very easy to get jet skis
in thailand yeah i remember i saw a
sheet that was like
it was like accidents by race or
something right it was like 100 of
accidents in like some part of the us
was like all white people or something
and it was it was for it was for uh jet
ski jet ski
jet ski accidents for white people and i
was like yeah yeah uh
i've always wanted to try surfing
surfing was one thing i've always wanted
to try i've done surfing and i've had
i thought i would enjoy it but i weirdly
didn't it seems really hard it's really
really hard um it's not even so much
about like you know it's not like
snowboarding where like the biggest
obstacle is you're being scared to just
like go fast or whatever like it's
literally just like
it's the act of
standing up
from a really like rickety like whether
isn't still right and like that and you
do that a couple of times and you can't
even like get on your knees and then you
[ __ ] fall over and then you're hot
you you just snap you're like [ __ ] it i
can't do it yeah because like the one
time you can actually like stand up yeah
it's actually pretty easy to control
right right because just think of it
like snowboarding but with less friction
right so it's pretty easy to do
it's the standing up part that's like
[ __ ] impossible for me i don't know
what it is um and then when you when you
flip in
a in a surfboard it hurts yeah i can
imagine because the one thing that i'm
always afraid of is like what if i flip
off on the board and then the board just
[ __ ] smacks off yeah yeah yeah like
i've seen that happen to people and yeah
it looks like a really [ __ ] god
seeing them ride that wave is just so
[ __ ] cool
again i've never had the opportunity had
the opportunity like living in england
where are we going to find [ __ ] waves
you could go to cornwall i know but they
died
the way that waves are way too powerful
i think that was the problem as well
because like you know because we did it
for pe at one time because because our
score's rising the most australian thing
i've ever heard oh because our school's
laughing for pe because that school is
literally next to a beach so we just
like walk down five minutes down the
hill and it's like yeah there's a beach
right there you can surf um of course
there is yeah but it's scary dude for a
different reason that's so cool man i
wish i could i wish i could what's lots
of firsts we want to try you want to try
golf you want to try sailing surfing
surfing and sailing i want to try quad
biking yeah dude
i want to try them all actually yeah i
want to try them all yeah can we just
have like a sports festival day for
trash days yeah i just want to try all
of these things in one place yeah like i
just want to try more like extreme
sports you know what i mean it's you
tried skiing now you got a taste for the
extreme right yeah i got a taste of
adrenaline you know
yeah i'm still waiting for chris